- [Announcer] This program
is a presentation of UCTV
for educational and
noncommercial use only.
(retro electronic music)
- Welcome to a Conversation with History.
I'm Harry Kreisler of the Institute
of International Studies.
Our guest today is Susumu Shimazono,
who is professor in the
Department of Religious Studies
at the University of Tokyo.
He is the author of From
Salvation to Spirituality:
Popular Movements in Modern Japans.
And he is the 2010 Forster Lecture
on the UC Berkeley campus.
Professor, welcome to Berkeley.
- Thank you.
- Where you born and raised?
- I was born in Tokyo in 1948.
And I was raised there.
But I moved to another
local city named Kanazawa.
- And looking back, how
do you think your parents
shaped your thinking about the world?
- Oh yes, my father
was a psychiatrist and also
a university professor.
And he believed that science
to help people.
Thank you for pronouncing
my name (chuckles)
which might be difficult
to pronounce for the,
but what does it mean, Susumu?
That means progress.
So (chuckles) this I think reflects
the mentality of the
after-war period of Japan.
So my parents wanted me to
make Japan intellectually
progress. (chuckles)
- I see, and you ultimately wound up
doing religious studies.
Was there something in your background
that pointed in that direction?
- Mm-hm.
As you may know,
in Japan religion is
very complex. (chuckles)
My parents were married in 1945
before the war ended.
But the ceremony was in Shinto.
But my mother was educated
in Catholic schools
from elementary school
up to the university.
And my family belongs
to a Buddhist temple.
So we die,
and we make ceremony in Buddhism.
And my, as I said, my father
has some faith in modern
science and technology.
So (chuckles), it's been complex.
- That's so interesting,
because one of the themes,
and we'll talk about
this later in your book,
in fact, you had an
essay on the relation of
spiritual, the new religions in Japan
to psychology and psychotherapy.
And there's an important connection there.
- Yes, yes, I think so.
So my father believed
that he's helping people.
And the medical doctor
is a profession which is
special, you know. (chuckles)
So I think there is
something close to religion.
- In that.
- Yes.
- What were you trained as
in your college studies, and how did it
point the path toward religious studies?
- So when I entered the university,
I took the course for medicine.
So first I intended to
be a medical doctor.
And I chose the medicine because
it is about religion.
Interacting with, ah no, no,
it is about human beings.
In medicine, doctors will
interact with people.
And I like that.
But when I started to study medicine,
I thought it not be like that.
The contemporary medicine
is more scientific,
and they are looking at body
as like things, (chuckles)
not the human beings.
- The spirit.
- Spirit, maybe.
- Yeah.
- Yes.
So I was disappointed, and I changed
my field from medicine to religion.
- And how are you trained?
Are you trained as a sociologist?
Or as an anthropologist, or what?
- I was in the University of Tokyo.
The faculty of letters,
there's a department
of religious studies, mm-hm.
I think in Japan there
is religious studies
is very big, you know.
And they deal with Buddhism,
Shinto, Christianity,
and folk religion.
Very mixed.
And I liked the professors. (chuckles)
So my parents was very much disappointed
that I changed my mind.
- They wanted you to be a doctor.
- Yes.
And they didn't like to say that
their son is studying religion. (chuckles)
- (laughing) But as a scientist, right?
You are a social scientist
studying religion.
- So there are two big,
sort of big schools
in Japanese religious studies.
In Kyoto, the religious studies is
more oriented to philosophy.
And in the University of
Tokyo where I studied,
religious studies is more
oriented to social sciences.
But I think religious studies
is not science, I think.
And literature, art,
philosophy, thought;
I was also interested in that.
- And what did you do
your dissertation on?
- My first, oh...
My BA thesis is of Sigmund Freud,
(chuckles) the psychoanalyst.
And then for the MA thesis,
I studied Japanese folklorist,
folkloric studies.
- And let me ask you then now,
before we talk about
your work and your ideas,
what are the skills required, you think,
to study religion in
a nuanced, subtle way.
- So this is a problem
that in religious studies,
there is no definite, clear methodology.
If you want to study classical texts,
you must learn languages.
This is a very important
areas of religious studies.
There are other ways.
And first I didn't know
what kind of methodologies
I can learn.
And later I
started the...
what is called field work.
So I walked around
the city and meet people
and interviewed.
- It would seem that in religious studies,
because of the way
secularists dismiss religion,
that if you're gonna do the
kind of work you do well,
you really have to be respectful
of the people you're studying.
That is, really come to understand
what you call the magical
religious elements
of their belief system.
Is that hard to do?
Or do you learn to do that,
let me put it that way?
- So I think what motivate us
is the interest in other people.
So to understand how they think,
and curiosity.
So I think this is a bit
similar to anthropology,
and also the psychiatry.
So difference is very important,
and from understanding
the different people
to know ourselves, who we are.
So this is, I think, a basic methodology.
- And what is very clear
in the New Age religions
in Japan, which we'll
talk about in a minute,
is that these individuals are
struggling to come
to a way to deal with
the modern environment.
- Right, right.
So many Japanese would say that
they are not related to religion,
they don't like religion.
But I think
when they say that, the common religion
is technology-defined.
So in fact, they interested in religious
or spiritual matters very much.
Myself too.
- Yeah, and do you,
looking at yourself as a scholar,
do these kinds of studies require
that you have a certain
kind of temperament?
Tell us a little about yourself
as you do this work.
- Yes.
When I was a student,
it was a complicated time.
It was around 1970.
In Japan too, there was demonstrations
against the Vietnam War
and the university administration.
And I was involved in it.
And I was also very much confused.
I insisted that I'm on
the side of justice.
But when looking back,
reflecting on myself,
I didn't have any, you know,
important experiences, any
firm sense of, you know,
principles, ethics.
So I want to think by myself
on these issues,
but not from only the classical texts
or big thinkers, but
from the ordinary people
who we can learn respect.
- So in a way it's sort
of answering questions
for yourself, about questions of ethics,
principles, how to deal with the world;
and looking at your contemporaries
in contexts that one
might normally not look
if you were a secularist.
- Mm-hm.
- Yeah.
You did some of the early work
on the Aum Shinrikyo,
which was a religious
New Age group that became much more,
and in the end wound up
being a terrorist group.
Talk a little about how you,
as just an example of how you
came to understand that group overtime.
- Okay.
So first I studied
folklore and folklorist.
But then I realized that
folklore is interesting, but they are
already outmoded, obsolete.
- Outmoded, yeah.
(chuckles)
- They would disappear soon.
So I wanted to study things
which are living, which are reactive,
and which will affect our future.
And then I chose what
we call new religions.
And the term new religions
may be a little bit different
in the nuance of the term here.
In Japan, the Shinto and Buddhism
are main religions, but they're mixed.
So when the new groups appear,
it is not important whether
they are Buddhism or Shinto,
but they're different from the traditional
established (mumbles) groups,
and we call them altogether new religions.
And the main new religion started
in the early 19th century.
I first studied
those older new religions.
I liked the founders, foundresses.
There are not educated people,
but they are very creative.
They have the deep spiritual senses.
And I worked with
the teachers, you know,
priests of these groups.
And I can respect them.
So my first study of new
religions are very sympathetic.
But later I learned that
new religions altogether
are not good, (chuckles)
only not good.
But they--
- They're complicated.
- Complicated, they may have bad defects.
And recently...
Many people who are
involved in new religions
lose many things.
- Lose?
- Many things.
- Yeah.
They are for the poor heart.
Their relationships are destroyed.
So I became more and more critical.
And then what we call new new religions,
the groups which are more violent,
which are more aggressive,
they became more powerful.
And then that incident occurred,
the terrorist attack of
Aum Shinrikyo in 1995.
- This was the sarin gas released
in the Tokyo subway by Aum Shinrikyo.
- Yes.
- Yeah.
- And at the time, the school of religions
were very much accused
because they didn't warn
against the dangers of these groups.
So it was a hard time for me too.
- To deal with the subject matter.
I mean, it raised real questions about
your responsibilities as a researcher.
- Right, right.
- Yeah, yeah.
Now let's understand the new,
when you talk about
religion, whether old or new,
help us understand what
you mean by religion.
- Oh, yes.
It is very difficult, it isn't a topic
which is discussed very often.
Maybe since the, about 1990.
Many people now realized
that the term religion
is not easy to use.
It is used in such a complicated way.
We cannot use the word safely.
If I talk about religion,
you might think about
it in a different way.
So the communication's not easy.
And now I am working that
how the term religion
is translated in Japan.
The religion is the Western word,
and when it was translated into Japan,
there were many difficulties.
(chuckles)
- Such as, yeah.
- Yeah, such as, yes,
for example, Confucianism is
very influential in Japan,
(mumbles) religion.
Many discussions.
- Is it a religion, is that the question?
- If you take the term broadly,
it is religion.
But I must explain
in what sense first is use religion.
Yes, so...
- You say in your book that
beings, power or experience
that cannot be confirmed
by the five senses;
something that gives meaning,
strongly influences a
person and continuously
lead their thoughts and actions.
- Mm-hm, yes.
So...
(chuckles)
- Okay, and religion,
in the whole theory of modernization,
was something that was very,
the study was influenced by Weber.
And Weber thought that
the magical religious
elements would disappear, but part of
the implications of what
you're writing about
is that it doesn't disappear,
it's sublimated in a way.
and old questions arise anew.
And this was something
that the secular world
discovered in the 1970s,
therefore the search for new religions
became a global phenomena.
- So in, around 1970,
when I was a student,
many political movements there were,
but they were not religious.
For example, in Paris
there was a student revolution,
but it is influenced by Marxism,
or socialist kind of ideology.
It was secularist.
In Czechoslovakia there was a
new socialist movement with a human face,
but it was still socialist.
And in China, Maoist movement.
But in the '80s,
many of the new political movements
were motivated
somewhat by religions.
It is your area, really. (chuckles)
After the Iranian revolution,
in Philippines, for
example, the democratization
was much helped by Catholic organizations.
And popular movements
helped by religions organizations.
So why
this happen?
I think the secularization
proceed to some point,
to a certain point,
because science, if you learn science
and modern technology, it can help you.
But there is a limit when you know
that human beings cannot live
only by secular knowledge.
And so there is a turn.
What they call desecularization
or re-sy-co-la-ri-za-tion.
And I think this is, there's a spread
since the 1970s.
- And what people are looking for
answers to questions,
and you suggest that a lot of this occurs
as they confront the
realities of human existence:
suffering, disease, illness;
and then the whole
momentum of modern life.
People are left with a
sense of uncertainty,
and they're looking for answers.
- Right, right.
So good example is the medicine.
Around 1970,
in the West, they started
the hospice movement.
Medicine has long helped people
to be cured, to be freed from diseases.
But they better lead to
how to live to die.
(chuckles) So,
but people who are, you know,
who have a very severe disease
of course are very conscious
about his own death;
his own death.
And those who cure them
must be aware that.
So suddenly they realize that,
but in medical department
in universities, they
don't teach about that.
So this is a new way
that modern institutions
have to learn about the
limit of secular knowledge,
the limit of modern
science, modern rationalism;
and to learn from the old
wisdoms of human beings.
- Interestingly enough,
one of the first people
we interviewed in the early
'80s was Norman Cousins
who was an American
writer who began writing
and influencing medical
education in the country
by arguing that there
were alternative issues.
You even have an essay in your book
on alternative sources of knowledge.
And so this is a much
larger phenomena globally
than just kinda just
new religions in Japan.
I mean, it's a kind of global search
by humanity for answers in a world
that seems inadequate because
it's become so secular
and so dismissive of religion.
- Yes, so Japan is an interesting example
that they started modernization
earlier than other
countries in Asia, in Africa;
maybe in other parts of the world.
- This is the Meiji Restoration.
- Yes, yes, in the middle 19th century.
So we were very eager to
learn from the West.
But there have been always
some sense of difference.
And we did not agree
with the principles,
with the basic way of behavior,
which I learned from the West.
And so there are many attempts to
adapting the Western way
but in our own way also.
So new religions are,
in a sense, one example.
And there are, for
example, the alternative
agricultural movements,
alternative medicine.
There are many alternative things.
- You discuss one
religion where the founder
of the religion was
really somebody interested
in soils and fertilizer and microbiology.
And talk a little about that,
what was the name of the religion,
but it evolved into a,
almost a kind of psychotherapy,
but also a religion, but
also a movement about
what you should eat.
- Yes, yes.
Interestingly, Shinto,
rather than Buddhism, has
influenced that kind of movements,
alternative knowledge movements,
I said in my book.
Oomoto-kyo is an important example.
This is very well known and studied
because it had a very
strong political impact.
But it has many other aspects.
This religion was very much
involving, for example, arts.
Most of the followers practiced
some arts, for example,
poems, making short poems,
Japanese poems,
or writing calligraphies
from arrangements, tea
ceremony, like that.
And in arts and also the
life technologies, so how to live,
aating, growing the crops.
They wanted to invent
their own ways, uh-huh.
And it has influenced in the West.
This is not the influence from Oomoto,
there is another important movement
named microbiotics.
This was...
transplanted from Japan to the West.
And now I think in the West,
this is a bigger movement.
- And let's kind of help people understand
the common elements in these movements.
And you compare these new religions
to what you call salvation movements.
So explain to us what salvation
religions movements are
and how they differ from
the New Age religions.
- Okay.
So...
Modern people, for modern people,
when they learned modern science,
still they say
there is something unique to religion.
And...
So, because
this will help people to be independent,
to think by themselves.
And if you, for example, face
the god above,
you'll be alone,
and you will
situate yourself in a fundamental way.
This is the fundamental self recognition.
And in what religions this,
what kind of religions this happens?
I think this is salvation religion.
Salvation religion regards
human suffering's very important,
also the limits of humanity;
for example, we must,
we cannot escape from hurting us,
violence, for example.
And we also cannot escape from
the death itself.
So there is an important limit.
We cannot...
escape from them.
But if you have faith,
you can overcome that limit.
This is the basic
very powerful, you know,
source of the idea
which motivated human beings.
And Christianity's a very good example,
and Buddhism too, Islam too.
So still they are spreading in the world.
They are helping people to,
to be,
confirm that you are yourself.
And new religions in Japan,
I think they are, in their own way,
salvation religions.
But I think now, we are
more and more conscious that
salvation religions have
their own limit too.
- And the important
point that you emphasize
in the book with
salvation religion is that
the turning, the catharsis
comes through faith,
but from an outside power.
There is a god or an entity
that confirms the salvation.
And it is most likely in other world,
not in this world that
that salvation comes.
- Yes, yes.
- And so, but the difference
with the new religions
are telling us something else.
They are putting the burden more
on the individual, and as I understand it,
the salvation is in this world.
- Yes, I am influence by Max Weber.
And in his book,
he said that
this worldliness and the...
As a worldliness or the
limit of realizing this worldliness;
this concept, the concept of world
is very important in his work.
What I found is that
traditional salvation religion
has much emphasis on
the other worldliness.
But immortality, there are new type of
salvation religions which
emphasize this worldliness.
The salvation occurs within this world.
This is especially
conspicuous in the East Asia.
And this trend from the other
worldly salvation religions
to this worldly salvation religion,
if they continue this
way, what comes next?
I think New Age, which
is called in the West,
is something here.
- What, you know, as I listen
to you and I read the book,
there is a point at which it's very clear
you're addressing a global phenomena.
And that it, in a way, it touches on
all kinds of movements we
see in the world today.
In California, for example,
the whole thing about
proper eating and how the
proper diet can change you,
to all, you know, many kinds of (mumbles).
So the question is when is it religious,
when are these things religious?
Where does, what elements
in these common phenomenas
make them religion?
Because if you're changing
a diet in the United States,
you're not doing it for religious reasons,
at least many people are not.
- So there is not one
common element which
defines religion; there are many ways.
So the term religion
is not the word which catches the essence,
the gathering of many elements.
But anyway, for modern people,
the sense of their limit
over a scientific knowledge
and the limit of the
method of modern science,
what is called reductionism;
knowing things in parts,
but not as a whole.
If you study diseases,
modern scientific medicine
studies the parts of your body,
not the person as a whole:
mind, body, spirit.
But we need to
acquire that kind of sense.
So this is, I think, a new
global awareness that we need
a different way of grasping
the world, and this is a basis which,
you know, there are many
different, what do you call it,
new spirituality movements,
new spirituality cultures
importing from different sources.
And many things are very
much commercialized.
But still there are many common elements,
and I think they can be
called religious too.
- Now you make an important
point in your book
about beginning with the Meiji Restoration
that there was as social basis
for the new religions and
their evolution overtime.
One element you identify is essentially
these religions emerged from the masses
as opposed from the elites.
Tell us about that and other elements
that tell us the social
basis of this phenomena that
you're describing throughout
the period of modernization.
- So if you, this is
(laughing) very big topic.
- Yeah. (chuckles)
Well what we're doing is
we're interesting people
so they go buy your book.
- Thank you for your careful review,
I'm very grateful.
If you look back the whole
history of religions,
and especially the salvation religions,
in the age, what we call Middle Ages,
some people have the major initiatives,
and other people just,
you know, following.
Of course, they were just not obeying
but they have their own way.
But it was not expressed.
But in the process of modernization,
people have their own, you know,
way of expressing themselves
and organizing themselves.
So this is different in Europe and the US.
In Europe, the church structure
has a still strong power.
So popular religious movements
are not welcome speakers.
But here in the United
States, there are many sects,
many religions movements,
and it represents the power of the people.
So religion has been changing that
the initiative moved from the elite
to the popular elements.
- You say in your book,
the new movements are
a reflection of radical individualism
that is necessitated by the affluence
and information-oriented
nature of contemporary society.
- Yes.
But so,
in the case of Japan,
in the 19th century and until about 1970,
popular religious movements
are very much com-mu-lar.
They like to form the local community,
local congregational community.
There are local leaders.
Many of them are housewives.
They are very powerful people.
They may not be
educated in the higher education.
But they have their own
very powerful personal experience,
they have their own source of wisdom.
But after the 1970s, that kind of,
it was not easy to form
that kind of community
in their localities.
And when they gather,
for example, there is an, you know,
screen, TV screen, and
they watch (chuckles)
the same TV screen, but
they don't talk each other.
So this is a new way,
and they don't know how to interact
for the very important
existential things.
This is related to what is called New Age
in the United States.
- So you're suggesting that the weakness
of these new religions, in addition to
their veering off course
and becoming extremists,
as we talked about earlier,
is that they may not be creating
an institutional structure
for social cohesion.
So the burden of everything, of changing,
finding catharsis,
falls on the individual.
- Yes.
So salvation religions
were so influential in human history
because they are the way,
they taught the way to form community.
But recently, salvation religions
sometimes help individuals
to feel that you are yourself,
but they do not help
construct stable community
which can convey the traditions.
So this is a difficult time.
So the dangerous elements
of salvation religions,
for example, excluding the other people.
- That is, people who have not been saved
are outsiders, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And the auth-it-ar-ian element.
This was in some groups,
this became, this is becoming
very much to, you know,
to be warned against, yes.
- What are the political implications
of New Age religions?
I would imagine it varies
country by country.
In the United States,
religious fundamentalism
has become important
in electoral politics.
It's linked to the anti-abortion movement.
What is the story in Japan,
and then what do you think
the global implications are?
- Yes, I didn't discuss
about this in this book.
But the religions which are
politically influential
in contemporary world
are not only salvation religions.
In Japan, the state Shinto
is very important.
It doesn't teach individuals
to be independent and to learn about
how to be saved.
But it gives people the
sense that they are powerful
and they can be united,
and sometimes they, it can be aggressive.
In India, so what is
called Hindu nationalism,
is very powerful.
In Japan, there was always
the religious power,
which are different from
salvation religions.
Buddhism and Shinto, Confucian
type of religious ideology.
And I think in contemporary Japan,
this kind of nationalist religious
ideology, this is also
to be carefully examined.
- When, are there factors
that you can identify in
the case of Aum Shinrikyo
where they go off the road, so to speak.
In other words, is it that the,
is it the mixing of it with
authoritarian leadership,
or is the, it seems to have become
a moneymaking entity?
Is it that the market intruded?
What makes New Age religions go astray?
- In my, you know,
theoretical scheme, Aum Shinrikyo
is not close to New Age, New Age type
of religious phenomena.
It is more a communal.
It is not very individualistic.
It denied family, family.
- It denied family.
- Family, yes.
So this is very much against
traditional Japanese morality.
So...
The loss of the sense of the
continuity from the past,
this was very strong.
And I think,
this is why the younger people,
and especially educated people,
were attracted by this group.
And this became very dangerous.
- To what extent, when you
examine these religions,
have they been influenced by a sense
of the apocalyptic that might come
from the fact that Japan was a victim
of the use of the first atomic bomb?
Does that enter into this at all,
or are these New Age religions
not relating to that at all?
(Susumu chuckles)
- The Aum Shinrikyo
used many (chuckles)
different ideas, for example, Nostradamus
was used by them very effectively.
And Christian apocalyptic ideas
was employed by them.
Some Buddhist
prophetic elements was also used.
So...
very new, but they inherited
many things from the popular
religions movements in Japan.
And this was not very much
emphasized by our scholarship
but from the magistration on,
there are many religious movements,
popular religious movements;
the scholars emphasized
they were oppressed
by the totalist government.
But popular movements helped
to make the totalian, you know,
social system in the 1930s.
So there was always the danger.
So it was so rapid in the,
the group started in the mid 1980s,
and the mid '90s,
only after 10 years after they started
they caused such a big--
(voices interposing)
- Yes, yes, the incident.
It was difficult to prognose.
But there was always that kind of element.
Popular religious movements can become
the dangerous element, yes.
- One final question, a brief answer,
for our audience out there,
is there one point of departure when they
confront new religions,
say, in the United States
or else where?
One idea that you would
like to leave them with
as a result of your studies to,
because you started by
saying you were interested
in understanding people and why they
were returning to this
religious phenomena.
Is there one insight that
stands out in your work?
- Yes.
So...
Human beings, (chuckles)
I'm saying us, two big
things right now. (chuckles)
Human beings are weak.
You cannot control yourself.
We must help each other.
And when we help each other,
and when we overcome the violence,
we need something beyond us.
So religion
is so essential for human beings.
But it can be also
the dividing, aggressive forces.
So what make you strong
may make you dangerous.
So this kind of a paradox
we must face, and you know,
we must deal with our reason.
- On that note, let me
show your book again
because I think it's very lucid
and people will find it instructive,
even if they're not interested primarily
in religious movements in Japan,
but rather the global phenomena.
Let me thank you very much
again for being our guest
on Conversations with--
- Thank you very much.
- History; and thank you very much
for joining us for this
Conversation with History.
(retro electronic music)